bonsoir nous prenons merci d'être avec
nous alors avant toute chose comment
s'est passée cette première journée
d'école à distance pour vous on sait
qu'il ya eu beaucoup de bugs un peu
partout en france c'était le cas
également chez vous oui bonsoir leurs
victimes en vous dire que la matinée
était assez catastrophique moi j'ai des
tas de parents qui m'ont appelé
ou par sms ou par mail est le mot qui
revenait tout temps concédé parce que ça
va juste pas marché alors c'est à dire
ça n'a pas marché ça veut dire qu'il y
avait quand même des courants vision qui
étaient prévues dans la plupart des cas
c'est ça chez vous alors ça ça dépend ce
que c'était plutôt par niveau c'est à
dire que sur les écoles maternelles
élémentaires étaient pas tellement des
cours qui était prévu il ya eu des
pochettes donné il ya eu des choses mois
après il fallait se connecter pour dire
où on en était donc les système marchait
pas très bien en collège par contre on
passait de toute présence à tous
distance donc bah c'était quand même
compliqué pour les professeurs au
dernier moment d'organiser quelque chose
et découvrir ce matin qu'on n'y avaient
pas accès parce que les serveurs
marchait pas ouais c'était vraiment
vraiment pas une bonne bonne surprise il
ya c'est pareil oui au lycée c'est
pareil bien sûr philippe renault ya
aussi quelque chose dont on parle peu
parce qu'il ya souvent une communication
de la part notamment du ministre de
l'éducation qui nous explique d'ailleurs
lors du premier confinement que tout
s'était très bien passée l'enseignement
à distance qui remercier les professeurs
mais il ya quand même beaucoup
d'inégalités enfin vous m'arrêtez si je
me trompe m'envahir certaines écoles qui
bras qui ne donne que des devoirs il n'y
a pas du tout de visio ya rien quand
d'autres ont peut-être de la
visioconférence toute la journée ça
devient compliqué peut-être aussi pour
les parents à gérer ce problème
l'inégalité effectivement long on le
voit où l'entend on le ressent parce que
même à l'intérieur d'un établissement ça
peut dépendre aussi de fonds va dire de
la motivation mais surtout de
l'équipement des professeurs parce
qu'ils n'ont pas tous ce qu'il faut ça
dépend aussi de du service informatique
de des systèmes informatiques des
établissements parce que
avec les lois de décentralisation c'est
les mairies c'est voilà les
collectivités territoriales et c'est
assez inégal donc oui et après pour les
enfants eux mêmes c'est pareil dans les
familles je veux dire il ya des familles
où on est équipé on a la place on arrive
à le faire bien il ya d'autres familles
c'est très très compliqué de le faire
donc on a vu des forts décrochages au
premier confinement nous craint
énormément de revoir les mêmes mais ça
veut dire que du côté en tout cas des
professeurs il n'y a pas vraiment
d'obligations télétravail si j'ose dire
c'est vrai que dans le privé on connaît
tous le télétravail et il ya une
obligation voilà d'être présents devant
son ordinateur pour les profs n'y a pas
d'obligation finalement d'être là et
surtout ne leur en donnent pas toujours
les moyens aussi
alors ils en n'ont pas toujours les
moyens il ya une obligation et travail
après c'est pas pour ça qu'ils font leur
travail sous forme de cours à distance
ça paie parfois des choses qui sont
donnés aux élèves et des professeurs
sont juste là pour être disponible pour
pour répondre à des questions où il ya
des contrôles contre le plus tard donc
voila mais d'ailleurs c'est un peu
l'ambiguïté c'est quand on parle de
cours à distance ces infos mots c'est on
appelle ça une continuité pédagogique et
ensuite chaque enseignant on va dire est
libre de la façon dont ils appliquent
motifs en fait il doit faire respecter
les programmes et doit continuer à ce
que les élèves suivent pas il le fait de
faire à sa façon mais ça génère de la
compréhension chez les familles et la
frustration et l'énervement
effectivement alors vous c'est important
de dire quelle va être fait payer vous
ne demandez pas la fermeture des écoles
et pourtant les clac permet les unes
après les autres avant ce confinement
aujourd'hui quel est votre sentiment il
n'y avait pas le choix
là où on était arrivés tard ce qui est
terrible c'est d'en être arrivé là parce
que effectivement ça fait un an que
confinement et là je veux dire il ya un
an
d'ailleurs si on avait fait des choses
mais un an plus tard que ça soit
toujours pas prêt qui le bug de ce matin
c'était vraiment le voilà si on voulait
être convaincu que rien n'a été préparé
c'est bon on est convaincu 1
mais voilà mais nous on est enfin on est
désolé on ne demandait pas on n'en est
pas là fermeture des écoles ont demandé
qu'en fait il ya un protocole on n'est
pas médecin on nie pas et yb
épidémiologistes on demande d ascq
protocole défini par l'état soient
appliquées il n'a pas été appliquée
parce qu'il y avait pas d personnel
suffisant et il n'y avait pas les
matériels
voilà ça manquait d'argent ça manquait
de personnes donc à la fin gouvernement
il n'arrivait plus à faire appliquer
protocole donc bah il a décidé de faire
du tout est différent
nous ce qu'on se pose comme question
c'est à la rentrée parce qu'il y aura
une rentrée en l'espère
comment ça va se passer qu'est ce qui va
se passer qu'est-ce qui va était alors
on nous avait promis un tout de même on
s'en souvient des tests salivaires
c'était les grandes annonces de des
dernières conférences de presse en il ya
quelques semaines d'olivier ferrand et
de jean castex
c'est à cet hiver dans les écoles vous
en avez vu la couleur ou oui alors dans
notre département on suit près avec avec
les autorités le rythme c'était à peu
près sur le val d'oise département c'est
à peu près de 1000 par jour
ça fait un chiffre qui fait impression
quand le multiplie par le nombre
d'élèves
bah c'est quand même pas énormément donc
c'était un début on attendait
l'accélération bombe à la tension s'est
arrêté donc c'est pareil c'est à la
rentrée est ce qu'il y aura des moyens
décuplés pour tester plus fréquemment
plus fréquemment et tous les élèves
en tout cas tous ceux dont les familles
souhaitent que ça soit fait ces foyers
on a surtout eu des villes de valade et
des associations et cpe dans des vies
qu'ils disaient et nous quand est ce que
c'est il ya des écoles qui ont jamais ça
ni vers des villes complètes ont pas eu
test salivaire du tout il ya aussi une
autre chose que ce qu'on attendait dans
l'enseignement dans l'éducation
nationale c'était peut-être la
vaccination en priorité des enseignants
et ce appareil peut-être douche froide
avec la dernière conférence de presse
emmanuel macron sauf erreur de ma part
les enseignements passeront entre
guillemets avec les autres à partir du
15 juin en tout cas en fonction de leur
âge tout simplement mais ya pas une
priorisation il aurait peut-être fallu
le faire alors
je fais le même constat go c'est à dire
qu'au début on a commencé à novembre que
les enseignants seraient vaccinés on
sait tous ce qui se passe sur le manque
de doses de vaccins on va dire au niveau
global
donc on avait énormément de doutes bon à
la limite là les doutes sont levés on
sait que les enseignants ce n'est pas
vacciné le 26 avril
quand l'école est censé reprendre dans
le premier degré et donc voilà j'ai
entendu mi juin tout à l'heure dans
votre documentaire bon même mich voilà
j'en sais rien mais mais non les
enseignants seront pas vaccinés à la
rentrée donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est
ce qui se passe vous voyez c'est quand
même ça qui est compliqué c'est qu'on
voit de l'improvisation au fur et à
mesure c'est toujours des décisions
prises au dernier moment et il a même
trois semaines à l'avant ce qu'est ce
qui va se passer on sait rien on sent un
petit peu votre désarroi
c'est le cas de nombreux parents
évidemment en france aujourd'hui
vous pensez comme le gouvernement avait
l'air de dire que on a poussé au maximum
qu'on est resté le plus ouvert possible
dans l'est dans les écoles contrairement
aux autres pays où vous êtes quand même
inquiet pour cette nouvelle année
scolaire de nos enfants
plus qu'un pied parce que il ya
effectivement des anglais enfin voilà il
ya des élèves qui sont voilà qu avait
tenu le coup on va dire au premier
trimestre
qu'on a fait les conseils de classe de
premier deuxième trimestre et au
deuxième trimestre ils ont commencé à
lâcher donc il ya toute une partie des
jeunes qui voient là kik
voilà qui sont partis que tak ont
décroché on les verra pas pendant qu'on
filantes sont nous on a les premières
stats de combien d'élèves étaient en
visio pour les rares visites organisées
dans les lycées c'est très bas mais
après on a aussi le problème inverse
c'est à dire qu'on a des élèves qui
étaient bons voire très bons et c'est
terrible à dire mais ils sont en train
de saturer c'est à dire que dans les
lycées on a vu en première et en
terminale les élèves qui sature qui n'en
peuvent plus psychologiquement ils vont
pas bien
les professeurs et l'administration à la
direction de mon lycée ont fait le même
constat et on passe donc ça éclate par
les deux bouts et on voit rien voilà
parce qu'il faut préciser philippe
renault dit c'est important parce que ce
qu'il faut préciser que c'est qu'avant
les fermetures il y avait beaucoup de
classe soit déjà fermé et sa famille
mais on imagine ces jeunes samyn sabine
et les familles parce qu'en fait la
semaine dernière il y avait beaucoup de
colère dans les familles parce qu'on
voyait arriver les fermetures les unes
après les autres et personne n'osait
trop le dire sauf que ban ou les
constatait donc les familles étaient en
colère donc mercredi soir avec les
annonces et bien moment d'expectative on
va dire et puis ce matin la douche
froide quoi c'est à dire que tout ce qui
avait tenté d'être mis en place par par
des profs qu'on bossait ce week-end
enfin je veux dire voilà et on y avait
juste pas accès donc je sais pas dans
quel état à eux aussi ils sont mais y'a
rien je veux dire on a l'impression qu'à
rien on a l'impression qu'ils rien ça
fait un an que ça dure
il ya un an on a tenu le coup il ya un
an il y avait des initiatives avec
l'énergie avec l'imagination de tout le
monde
on n'est plus dans cet état là les
parents sont fatigués excédés et les
jeunes des jeunes sont vraiment
moralement fatigué il ya un truc que je
voudrais demander sais pas si je peux
mais les épreuves terminales de français
et de philo faut tout de suite dire
qu'elle passe en contrôle continu les
gamins ils passaient pas possible de
leur faire subir ça encore longtemps
merci beaucoup en tout cas philippe
renaud vice président de la fcpe du val
d'oise d'avoir été avec nous